hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my vixen finale video a whole
bunch of stuff happening today so stay
tuned for announcements after I get done
I know you're all wondering like what's
going on with the character in the
series so I'll try to explain what's
going on with it
so really the push of the finale is
vixen acknowledging her heritage and
embracing it she gets that big call to
action from her ancestors that manifests
after her sister takes the totem and I
was really happy to see that they wrote
her clever enough to use the spider in
an ingenious way like have it bite her
sister inside her wound so that it
reached her bloodstream faster those are
usually criticisms a lot of people lay
on characters where it's like how come
they didn't take them down an X Y Z way
it would have been so much faster I try
not to nitpick logic too much usually if
you want to pick something apart it's a
little more rewarding to pick apart a
character arc like if you feel it's
rewarding not rewarding I feel like this
for for what it is is actually pretty
good now yes the series was like five
minutes like really like less than five
minutes per episode because there's like
pre-roll post-roll but what it was meant
to do was introduce this character into
the flash arrow universe like this
shared universe with legends of tomorrow
and be kind of a test pilot proof of
concept for a digital series The CW
wants to develop more digital
programming it has access to a ton of
Warner Brothers DC Comics IP and just
not enough room in its broadcast
schedule but of course they cast the
series with the idea that it might go
live-action if it's popular enough the
problem is is that we don't really know
what their benchmark for popular is into
in terms of this vixen series they don't
really report numbers like a YouTube
video would like you can look at a
YouTube video and say oh it got X views
so it's you know it's super popular it's
not popular at all broadcast networks
are always really self-conscious about
stuff like that they don't want to like
pull their pants down and show you their
underpants but I totally love the series
and I feel like there are some things
that they can do with the cartoon that
they just can't do with live-action like
just look at the last thirty seconds of
this episode just see how many jokes
they cram in that would just be weird
inside a broadcast episode it'd be like
is this a sitcom is this the arrow
sitcom one of my favorite ones just in
this episode though is vixen kind of
calling the arrow a little bit racist
maybe he just like slaps his forehead
what I meant to say is that you don't
have enough training we'll call that the
Black Canary objection to becoming a
superhero overnight there is actually a
lot of Laurel stuff going on but I'll
just I'm gonna talk about that in my air
of it
you next week whenever the premiere
happens favorite moments though the
totem is meant to help me protect my
village
Detroit is my village that lets you know
vixen is gonna stay relatively local to
Detroit for now and the way they leave
things between the sisters you know
clearly like this sister character is
gonna come back and be a villain for
this series she'll be like a season 1
malcolm merlyn character the actual
merlin john barrowman relationship with
the rest of team arrow has changed quite
a bit in the last couple of seasons just
think of the sister is the Moriarty
character two vixens Sherlock Holmes if
the series gets a season two and they
expand it to like a full series that
gets like a full half-hour show he'll
introduce a lot more vixen villains from
the comics we might even see Animal Man
that'd actually be pretty cool just like
arrow runs into the green arrow quantity
problem and in terms of unique
characters to that universe I think that
vixen would borrow a lot from Justice
League villains to let me know in the
comments though what do you guys think
about Mixon as a series like would you
be excited for it to become its own show
like a full half hour or even an
hour-long show I say half hour just
because if it stays animated if it's
only gonna be an animated series it'll
probably only be a half hour long if
she's gonna be live-action only I
actually think she would work better
just bouncing from show to show like
going from arrow to the flash to legends
of tomorrow most of her best moments are
Justice League moments so why wouldn't
you put her in the team-up episode most
of the big questions that I saw from you
guys are just you know confusion over
like you know what is the intention with
this series like why are they putting a
five-minute episode on the Internet
really just proof of concept they just
want to see that the character is
popular that people like her now I just
posted a couple arrow and flash trailers
so I'll put some links in the
description for that but there's
actually some new news about arrow
season 4 Stephen Amell was just teasing
people on the internet this morning he
did the two truths 1 lie thing and I
actually I didn't see that it was a lie
so I just assumed all these were true
until I like I read a little bit more so
one I think the lie is that the Huntress
is in the premiere I don't think we're
gonna see the Huntress so that means
that he's probably going to Russia in
the flashbacks and he's going to kill
someone that's what he means by break
his know kill rule and since he didn't
make that rule until season 2 that might
end up happening in present-day
or or he could have just been miss
speaking and he could be killing someone
in the past all of her pre season 2
kills a lot of people and if you guys
didn't catch any of my Twitter feed from
this morning supposedly
there's going to be a big Doctor Who
announcement later today I mean as of me
posting this video it's supposed to be
around 4 p.m. maybe a new companion
we'll find out by the time I post this
we'll probably know what it is there is
an x-men apocalypse trailer that's
coming tomorrow
with the Martian so that'll probably be
my first video tomorrow so while you
guys wait for all that you can click
here to catch up with arrow and flash
Jones I just did a big Anarchy video
he's gonna be a big character in season
4 and you can click here to catch up
with all my Doctor Who videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys in a little
bit